there's a tick talk
that's gone viral from our friends over
at libs of tick tock one of the great
twitter accounts
of a
transgender satanist explaining
and he's got he's got all these facial
tattoos and lots of crazy piercings and
looks
it would seem intentionally very scary
he's obviously got a lot of problems and
he's explaining
the philosophical center of his
strange appearance
i'm just going to post this every time
people ask me the same questions over
and over again my name is farah i am a
trans woman as well as an intersex woman
my pronouns are she her they them are
your grace
my eyes are tattooed
my nose is a piercing
i identify as a threat a nightmare and a
goddess so please bow down to me i do
not believe in god i don't worship the
devil but yes i am a satanist which
means i am my own god and i worship
myself
thank you have a good day
so a lot of people are looking at this
and saying man
there's a lot of untreated mental
illness out there and i bet this person
has some psychological problems
but the person also has spiritual and
philosophical problems and today because
our our country operates in this very
materialist way
where we deny spiritual reality and it
makes us go kind of schizophrenic
because on the one hand we say there's
no such thing as the solar spirit we're
just meat puppets and
you know we're just bags of chemicals
but then on the other hand we say our
bodies don't mean anything and if we
think if i'm a man and i think i'm a
woman then i actually am a woman and the
physical world the flesh means nothing
and the spirit means everything and
we've got this really schizophrenic view
rather than the reality of the situation
which is that we're body and soul
combined right body and spirit together
so
the more interesting thing that this
person says is
beyond the eye tattoos and the face
tattoos and the giant piercing through
his nose and all that he says i'm a
satanist
but i don't believe in god and i don't
worship satan i worship myself
and i am a god and i'm a goddess
like as though this is some clever thing
you'll hear this from certain satanist
groups they say oh you we're just we're
using the word satanism kind of
ironically you don't we don't really
believe in gods and deities and devils
we just worship ourselves
as if that isn't what satanism always
was
that that is satanism that's what satan
did that's what made satan fall like
lightning from heaven it was satan
an angel
chose to worship himself and pursue his
own will rather than the will of god
this is just
straight out of the bible and then he
falls from heaven
and and goes down to hell this is what
john milton writes about in paradise
lost he says the mind is satan is saying
this when he's cast down into hell he
says the mind is its own place and can
make a heaven of hell and uh hell of
heaven
but but that isn't true you actually
can't do that and the more that the
satan in milton's paradise lost thinks
that way the the worse off he becomes
and eventually becomes a snake and he
and anywhere he turns he's stuck
in hell as are these people we'll get to
that in just one second first though did
you know that in just the last six years
over 100 000 farms and ranches in the
united states have shut down and you
know why because foreigners are stealing
their stuff and their market position
foreign meat is stealing their business
and robbing you of the quality and
flavor that you deserve that's why good
ranchers is here a lot of the meat that
you'll see in the grocery store that has
a kind of usa type label on it is
actually not from america it's actually
from other other countries and then it's
processed here don't do that the good
ranchers have gone out they have found
great american ranches really
exceptional quality beef better than
organic chicken really top quality stuff
i love the burgers mice to me the
burgers are absolutely out of this world
go to goodranchers.com knowles canada
wlas right now get 10 free bistro
fillets in addition if you subscribe you
will save 25 bucks off each subscription
box of mouth-watering american meats for
life
these boxes will show up on schedule
right to your door that is 10 free
bistro fillets that's a 119 value free
express shipping and 25 off your monthly
subscription for life at
goodranchers.com knowles
goodranchers.com knowles or use code
knowles at checkout 10 free bistro
filets free express shipping 25 bucks
off your monthly subscription for life
goodranchers.com
knowles if you pursue your own will
divorced from the moral order if you
pursue your own disordered desires
divorced from good
and if you pursue your own fantasies
divorced from reality you are going to
end up in hell
in the afterlife and in this life too
and in your personal life and in society
too
and that person in the who has all these
problems on tick tock
that person would seem to be living in a
kind of hell and maybe we all focus on
the chemical
reasons for that maybe this person needs
to take this drug or that drug or this
antidepressant or whatever but there's a
spiritual and philosophical issue here
too
and the same thing goes for our public
life the same thing goes for abortion
okay and and a lot of other political
issues but abortion is a pretty clear
one because it involves a mother killing
her own child
you you can't you can't escape it you
can't escape moral reality you can't you
can try
and a lot of people try even on the
right you know the left certainly tries
even on the right the kind of more
libertarian point of view is that we can
escape the moral order we don't need to
be beholden to any moral order it's just
our willfulness our choice our desires
that's all that really matters but it's
not it's not
and the men who developed our country
knew that
and great statesmen throughout history
have known that and we
stupidly have forgotten that and the
more we forget it the crappier our
country looks
and it's as simple as that hey man i'm
glad you like that clip or lady or
whatever however you identify thank you
for watching that clip you can subscribe
by ringing the bell getting all the
notifications for all the future videos
and if our friends here don't want to
give you the notifications i would
recommend you go to apple podcasts or
spotify or stitcher or google play
wherever you get your podcasts and
subscribe leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]